Rose has been served to be a pose. >> Ah, yes. In addition
to all the attention that I'm sure that she is getting and in
addition to all the Kiwi Farms users trying to like stalk her
in order to gain her hand in marriage, I bet, right? Cuz they
they love the idea of a supple 19year-old to marry. Okay. Um,
like like the thing is is that like why why is it like like I'm
sure she would love the idea of being served a subpoena by Pixie.
Champion of woman by the way. I'm sure after being predated on
possibly by a like sexual predator. Great stuff.
Read through with all y'all. Yeah. Okay. So we see here this
is Pixie's response in uh opposition to Destiny's motion to dismiss
for lack of jurisdiction. Introduction
defendant's motion is nothing more than an improper attempt to
shortcircuit plaintiff's core cardi claim. The motion rests entirely
on factual disputes whether his disclosures predated Cardi or
whether he disclosed the video to ABMC that go to the heart of
the plaintiff's cause of action. By styling his factual defenses
as a jurisdictional challenge, defendant seeks to have the court
resolve disputed merits questions on rule 12b1 motion. That is
not under the law. That is not the law. Under binding 11th circuit
precedent, when jurisdictional issues are intertwined with the
merits, as they are here, the court must assume jurisdiction
and deny dismissal. At most, defendants's arguments may be raised
on summary judgement after discovery is complete. For now, the
motion should be denied outright. Relevant procedural background.
Discovery closes December 16th, 2025. See order ECF23,
but it's still it is still in early stages. Written discovery
is ongoing and depositions have not yet been conducted. Written
discovery only began after the court granted plaintiffs protective
order on September 2nd, 2025, ECF-16.
Plaintiff produced over 3,000 documents on September 5th with
additional productions on September 22nd. Defendant, however,
delayed production until September 12th and provided incomplete,
deficient, and forensically unound materials. Okay. unound materials.
Right here, defendants's ESI was not collected was not collected
and preserved in a forensically sound manner. Thus, it cannot
be authenticated and is not reliable. See the declaration of
Jesus Pena, forensic expert, exhibit A here too, paragraph 16.
Moreover, there is evidence of tampering in foliation. Uh, same
reference, paragraphs 16 to 22. There are multiple factual disputes
pertaining to Benell's disclosure of the video that require further
discovery. Okay, so uh things that are going to work against
Destiny here. Okay, he went on a stream and talked about how
he was trying to construct the evidence he was going to submit
to the court. He talked about how difficult it was and then there
are obvious errors because he's a lazy piece of [__]
in the evidence he submitted. Like the URLs were clearly like
somehow copied with OCR, right? In a way that they're like missing
slashes and there's a whole bunch of other [__] going
on with them, right? So, there's like there's the record the
the food shops VOD where he complains about how he's not getting
the time stamps to line up correctly. And then there's even some
other minor things going on like timestamps just like missing.
Like in one of his in one of his things the time stamp appears
to just be different from the one from Rose's leaks. And I'm
not sure what would cause that to be honest with you cuz I you
would think they're serverside timestamps, right? They have to
be serverside timestamps because they have to be produced on
multiple devices and be consistent. So, it's weird that they
would be like changed in any way that makes them, you know, a
minute off, 2 minutes off. But we'll see. Maybe Mr. Pñena, the
expert,
has a different opinion or some some statement on this. We'll
see. Argument one, defendants's factual challenge must be denied
because jurisdiction and the merits are intertwined. defended
styles his motion as a rule 12B1 factual attack, arguing that
one, his disclosure to Rose occurred before Card's effective
date, and two, he did not disclose the video to ABMC after the
statute took effect. This argument goes to the heart of plaintiff's
substantive claim under Cardi and cannot be resolved at the pleading
stage. The 11th Circuit has long held that when jurisdictional
facts are intertwined with the merits, the disc, the district
court must assume jurisdiction and resolve the dispute as a direct
attack on the merits.
Okay, so they have some some precedent for this. Dismissal is
only is permitted only if the federal claim is immaterial, insubstantial
or frivolous.
Uh plaintiff's cardi claim is her central claim and plainly neither
immaterial nor frivolous. Accordingly, the court may not resolve
factual disputes or weigh competing evidence on this rule 12b1
motion. Defendants motion should be denied outright or treated
under rule 56 standards, meaning it must be denied as premature
and in any event because material facts remain in dispute. See
Lawrence 9:19 federal claims should not be dismissed on motion
for lack of subject matter jurisdiction when that determination
is intermeshed with the merits of the claim and when there is
a dispute as to a material fact. Okay. So this is very similar
to why we thought it wouldn't it would pass you know a subject
matter jurisdiction like a motion for dismissal. But I think
it might also we I think this is why we thought it would pass
is basically you have there are facts outstanding there are facts
um in dispute and you can't actually know whether or not this
case is material without without resolving that right and even
something as obvious as what date the messages were sent on like
when Rose received the video which I think we all agree is obviously
true like it's it's sorry it's obviously true that it was sent
in April and not in October but that hasn't been proven in front
of a court. Yeah. So, you have to prove that in front of a court.
You have to actually show like an expert. And it's possible that
without records directly from Discord, that can't even be proven,
right? You would need the the the untampered records from Discord
to really show that for sure and to convince like a jury of that.
Otherwise, it's just going to come down to who best makes the
arguments in court. A defendant's factual challenge is premature.
Since defendants's jurisdictional argument challenges the merits
of plaintiff's claim and discovery is in its early stages, it
is prudent to deny the motion without prejudice and decide the
jurisdictional dispute at the summary judgement stage. So, because
we haven't finished discovery, you're like literally saying we
um you're saying we don't have subject matter jurisdiction. You're
saying but we we don't even know all the information we could
know yet. So, how in the world are you even saying that, right?
Yeah. So, you it would be an emotion for summary judgement if
you haven't finished discovery. If there's still outstanding
discovery happening, right, you can't even file a motion to dismiss.
That's probably not not a thing you could do. They don't even
know what what they're going to get from discovery at this point.
Denying motion to So, they cite a case here. Um, it is prudent
to deny so denying motion to dismiss for lack of subject matter
jurisdiction because the defendant's contentions were indirect
if not direct attacks on the merits of the plaintiff's claims.
And those questions must be resolved at the summary judgement
stage after both parties have had an opportunity to develop the
record through discovery.
Okay, if that's true, man, like I don't see how you could possibly
be able to dismiss here. All right. Here, defendants's jurisdictional
challenge turns on disputed factual issues that require discovery
to resolve. the timing of his disclosure of plaintiff's video
to Rose, including whether it remained accessible to Rose and
the public after the effect of date of Cardi, as well as whether
or not he disclosed the images to ABMC. Yet, discovery in this
matter is far from complete. Cante and the evidence relied on
by defendant to support his argument is not reliable and cannot
be authenticated. C. Declaration J, PA, exhibit A, paragraphs
16 to 22. Plaintiff cannot fairly be required to meet her burden
of proof without the opportunity to complete discovery. C. Mikuel
Murray versus console this thing applying rule 56 standard to
rule 12B1 motion where the jurisdictional facts are intertwined
with the merits and denying the motion at this stage of the litig
litigation because discovery is not yet complete and plaintiff
is entitled to full discovery. Now I think at this point I'm
thinking I'm going to switch over. Give me a second. Let me go
ahead and switch over to the actual expert declaration because
at this point it's been referenced twice and I feel like it'
just be good to give it a look. Okay, so here it is. Let's take
a quick look at this. Let me get some water. All right. Declaration
of Jesus Pena. I, Jesus Pena, declare as follows. One, I am over
18 years. I'm not going to read the paragraph numbers. I am over
18 years of age. I am the founder of E-H forensics, Inc. E. Forensics.
And I have over 24 years of experience and my CV is attached
here too as exhibit A. My fields of specialty relate to digital
forensics and eiscocovery consulting and advisory services and
information security auditing and assessments to law firms, corporations,
municipalities, and federal agencies since 20 or since 2000.
My digital forensics experience includes evidence acquisition,
evidence analysis and reporting and expert witness testimony
as it applies to electronically stored information ESI found
on mobile devices, workstations, virtual and physical servers,
routing and filtering devices and cloud storage and computing
environments. So just like uh just like an expert, okay, an expert
in digital evidence, digital evidence for court cases, the preservation,
the collection, the
everything, okay? As part of my job duties and responsibilities,
I perform digital forensics and eiscocovery services and I oversee
the technicians who perform forensic inspections of information
technology assets. I personally review and analyze the the electronic
data in information that is mirror imaged and or otherwise retrieved
from those computers. In total, I have testified over 50 times
as either an expert or a fact witness in depositions, hearings,
trials in state and federal court. I have been certified as an
expert witness by the United States District Court for the Southern
District of Florida, the test the Texas Southern District Court,
the District Court of Maryland, and the Superior Court of the
State of California for the County of Los Angeles. I have provided
other testimony in the Miami Dade, Broward, Palm Beach, and Sarasota
County courts as a computer forensics expert and fact witness.
He's just going through his bonafides.
All right, just going through our bonafides here. I co-authored
three books covering Windows, Mac OS, and mobile phone forensics
written between 2021 and 2023. Entitled LRea
Sensia Sensia Dea investig
system Windows volume I dude am I supposed to use this? Am I
supposed to read this in a fake Spanish accent the whole time?
He authored some books, titles of which are in Spanish. All right.
I was a panelist at the 2019 judicial events/mssp
recovery legends of the boardroom conference and covered technology
as it relates to litigation, mediation, and ADR. In 2008, I was
a presenter at Naka Naka's
15th annual consultants conference and covered the impact of
eiscocovery and computer forensics on the financial expert. I
hope this guy's from Puerto Rico, too. I don't maybe. Okay. I
was engaged through e- forensics inc by plaintiff to perform
digital forensic services and to consult on eiscocovery related
matters with respect to the digital forensics analysis. I was
tasked with reviewing all materials produced in this matter including
analyzing pleadings declarations and responsive documents by
the defendant with a goal of testing the veracity of plaintiff's
allegations and defendants responses. The final opinions/conclusions
expressed in the declaration are exclusively my own and are based
on my professional expertise, training, and experience.
Okay. All right. Probably another family member working for free.
Seems to be a lot of those. Damn. Pixie's family is like rich
enough to afford anything. They are also connected enough to
have like tons of people willing to help and they have like all
of those people at the same time are family members. Yeah. It's
crazy. This is sounds like an unhinged family. Okay. It's It's
wild. This case pertains to plaintiff's claim pursuant to the
Intimate Image Protection Act
Cardi which went into effect on October 1st, 2022 that at least
one video of plaintiff and defendant having a encounter was made
accessible on the internet by defendant well after the law went
into effect. So this guy's their expert witness who's coming
in to say, "Okay, like I I know for a fact that these files were
available through the internet. I
I still I have like the same I think I have a close to equivalent
understanding with this guy on how Discord stores those files
on how they're served on the case law and stuff. I don't think
this is going to be something that actually holds up this idea
that it was persistent after the date of Cardi and so that would
be the reason Cardi would remain in effect. I don't think so.
But they are going to make that argument and they're going to
make a judge or a like a judge or somebody dismiss it, right?
to say no, no, no, that doesn't apply. So, they'll keep going
with this. I sort of think it has way too much uh there are too
many knock-on effects, like negative knockon effects. Like, if
you do this, basically, anybody who's ever shared like a a kind
of revenge ever, if it's like still stored somewhere, that would
be something you could sue them for. If they shared it like 20
years ago, you could still sue them for it if it was still persistent
in some server and accessible the entire time. I think that's
probably unreasonable. crimes should be things that you've like
intentfully done at some point like recently, right? Yeah. I
mean, you do have to try it. And I don't think it's like decided
that Cardi couldn't apply in this way. Um, if this was if this
was kept on the internet and persisted in a way that was slightly
less randomized, slightly less um, secure, I think they could
make this argument. So, they're probably going to try to make
it and maybe hope that, you know, judges and courts aren't the
most techn technologically savvy people. Shut it down. You could
still sue them if they had it up in a way that was accessible,
but it would have to have some logical way to find the file or
it would have to be indexed on search engines. And none of that
applies to Google Drive links or uh Discord CDN links. Like they
just don't get cached unless they're linked on some other page
or something, right? So like there's just no evidence that this
was accessed over and over again by other people through a means.
Uh how would we put it? It could be shared basically in the same
way a file could be shared. I think would be the argument you'd
make from the other side. Uh, I could try to get into explaining
this later, maybe after we read the document. I That's how I
think it'll work. Anyway, keep going. Dissemination of the video.
In defendant's motion to dismiss at 12, paragraph 1. The defendant
alleges that the video is named vid
MP4 and contend that he transferred it to a Discord user with
the screen name Rose on April 9th, 2022.
So, at 12, hold on a second. Let me go let me fire this up and
see if we can find what this is specifically.
Give me a second. This should be attachment 12. No, 12, paragraph
1. Could it be paragraph 12 here? Nope. I don't know what this
is here. Give me a second. I'm going to try to find what he's
referencing cuz I don't know if it's that Excel document. Okay,
so we're referring to this Tashier 2 is exhibit D is a true and
correct screenshot of a post by Solo Tiny Leaks on Kiwi Farms
depicting the original file name of the video as this. The file
name provides a unique identifier for the video which against
which other files can be compared. It also confirms that the
video file was transferred directly through Discord as an attached
MP4 file and not transmitted via Google Drive link. Wait, maybe
in any case. Oh, cuz the file name is there. Sure, sure, sure.
Probably. Um, which against which other files can be compared?
I don't know that this necessarily holds up in court that like,
oh, if the file names don't match, you must acquit. I don't think
that if the file names don't fit, you must acquit is probably
not an argument you can do with something totally mutable. Okay.
So, and contend that he transferred it to a Discord user with
the screen name Rose on April 9th, which is prior to the effective
date of the Cardi statute. As will be discussed below, the evidence
relied on by defendant to support this April 9th date is inconsistent
and appears to have been tampered with. Thus, this has not yet
been conclusively established and would require further discovery.
However, for the purposes of the following continuing accessibility
analysis, I will assume the date of initial disclosure was April
9th, 2022.
On November 29th, 2024, 29 of the defendants files were posted
to Kiwi Farms platform by an individual with the Kiwi Farm screen
name, Solo Tiny Leaks, who created an account on the very same
day. See image one of exhibit D here too. One one of the 29 files
was the video as defined in the amended complaint. So this is
the video Pixie is what they call the video in these court documents.
The public thing is a red herring by Destiny. I think Pixie said
in a previous filing that the public doesn't matter. That being
public doesn't matter. Just sending it is what the law requires.
If I recall correctly, yes, sending it is what the law requires.
But he sent it before the effective date of Cardi and it was
remained accessible after the initial date of Cardi. So for this
argument, they're trying to say, well, it remained accessible.
So the initial violation that happened before Cardi is still
a violation. So it that is why like sending it is the big thing.
So if they get the Abby stuff if if that remains in then obviously
that happened after and that wouldn't have any problems. But
but for the initial disclosure that's probably on April 10th
2022 before Cardi. Therefore federal laws like this federal statutes
don't apply retroactively. You can't like apply it to to previous
crimes. So the if descending is the only thing that counts that
happened before the law came into effect. But thank you for the
question,
Okay. The leaked files originated from Discord as can be seen
by two of the file names prepended with spoiler underscore. See
image three of discore of exhibit D here too. The file naming
convention is unique to Discord and applied whenever an attach
and is applied whenever an attachment is added and the user flags
it as spoiler. The fact that some of the leaked files begin with
spoiler underscore indicates that the hacked files originated
from a Discord account that either sent or received the files.
In the case of the video, it could have been attained from accessing
Rose's or defendants's Discord accounts. In paragraph 12 of defendants's
declaration docket 132-1, defendant claims the leak likely came
from a compromise of Rose's Discord account. This has not yet
been conclusively established and would require further discovery.
Oh, that's interesting. So, I think what they're going to do
is they're going to have a bunch of factual claims that can't
be resolved or haven't been resolved yet, right? So, they survive
the the subject matter jurisdiction thing. They're just going
to keep pointing out cases of like ambiguous facts, things they
don't know for sure yet, right? Especially things that one side
is claiming. So, hey, Destiny claimed that it likely came from
the comprom compromising of Rose's account, but that's not conclusively
established. We need to answer that. We'll need discovery on
that. That makes sense to me. After defendant's disclosure of
the video, the video remained on Discord's content delivery network
CDN until it was finally deleted by defendant here. Hold on.
What is the What is this? A geographically distributed network
of proxy servers in their data centers. The goal is to provide
high availability and high performance by distributing the service
spatially relative to the end users. Wow, this guy knows what
a CDN is. What an expert. till it was finally deleted by defendant
after the November 29th, 2024 Kiwi Farms post by Solo Tiny Leaks.
Between April 9th, 2022 through at least sometime in December
2023, the video had uh 2024, this would be the video had continuous/ongoing
posting with unprotected unrestricted accessibility initiated
by the defendant by means of either direct use of a uniform resource
locator URL or via queries to any number of search engines. Uh
examples Google, Bing. This unprotected unrestricted access accessibility
of the video is a result of how Discord implemented storage and
access of messages uh of message attachments on its CDN servers
that cache Discord's attachments. Um
so he's saying it's accessible via a URL
or accessible via search engines. Now I don't know what he means
by accessible via search engines. I do not believe that you can
index
Discord CDNs. I don't think that's ever happened, right? like
they would not be crawled by web crawlers to be indexed in like
Google or Bing or anything like that. So I I have no idea. Like
you can't even you can't even walk the the tree structure.
So I don't I don't think that's actually true.
Uh yeah, I don't think that's actually true. He gets into that.
Okay. So like it could be via some text on some other site he
addresses it. Well, hold on. I didn't read. Okay, I'll get it.
I'll I'll go. I'll go. I'll continue. Between April 22nd, 2021
and up until sometime in December 2023, when the vulnerability
was finally rectified, Discord was known to have a significant
security issue wherein all attachments sent messages were permanently
publicly accessible from the CDN servers simply by navigating
to a permanent web address that pointed to the attachment. See
exhibit C herein of a Discord community forum post taken from
way back machine titled privacy for CDN attachments where it
first describes the issue back in 2021. This major security hole
resulted in bad actors using the platform for malware distribution.
The news regarding this issue and resolution went public and
was widely distributed on many popular uh outlets in early November
2023. Below are links to a few of the posted articles. So this
is something I pointed out, but this is not uh this is not resolving
that. This is not actually addressing that. Okay, just so you
guys know, this is actually a slightly different issue. This
is um when Discord added I think timeouts and keys to their their
file URLs or something, right? So, if you go and click a file
like later in some in some DM you have access to, it'll actually
open up a new URL that has a like timed link that's going to
be that will go dead after some amount of time. I think it's
like a week, a month, something like that. They used to never
expire. And the the reason they fixed it wasn't even necessarily
only because of malware. It was because people were like, I'm
sure somebody wrote like a file system on Discord, like using
just Discord CDNs. Like Discord was just infinite storage for
all the stuff you ever wanted to store. And I think they just
wanted things to start expiring,
right? Anyway, to address this the vulnerability and the issue
that doesn't say that any of this stuff is actually crawled by
search engines, but he also talks about indexing, I think. Well,
not yet. To address the vulnerability of the issue of permanent
accessibility, in December of 2023, Discord implemented authentication
enforcement, which basically replaced permanent links to attachments
with temporary ones that expire within 24 hours. By doing so,
Discord effectively solved the problem of its CDN servers hosting
malware. Equally important, the change also resulted in the inability
of search engines like Google and Bing to index attachment files
because when the engine's crawlers returned a day or later, the
URLs expired and the engines would not be able to find the files
to index. Okay, so but here's the thing. you can't walk the structure
of like of the CDN like the actual file stored in the CDN. So
there's no way for the the crawler to index it unless somebody
else has posted it to the internet, right? That's that would
be how that works. So somebody else would have had to post it
to the internet at some point for it to get indexed by those
crawlers. So, search engine indexing is the process by which
a search engine such as Google crawls, analyzes, and stores resources,
URLs,
metadata, and content such as text and PDFs or text files, captions
for videos, examples, MP4, or alt text for images to make them
discoverable in search results. Yeah. So, I think I I'm still
pretty confident that what I'm thinking he's he's like saying
this, but I don't I don't think this necessarily holds up. We'll
see. We'll see. We'll see. Okay. Continuing continuing. Discord
generates the new temporary URLs with authentication enforcement
in the background which appends some parameters to the old URL
style in part to identify expiration date. The new style temporary
link creation occurs in the background only if the recipient
or sender of the attachment views the message with the attachment.
At that point, Discord's application, Discord's API, will render
the message on the application screen and automatically creates
the new temporary link. What is important to note is that once
authentication enforcement went into effect in December of 2023,
any old style permanent URLs became obsolete and the attachments
were no longer reachable with the old style permanent URLs, but
the attachments physically remained on the CDN core and CDN servers.
Of importance is that both before and after implementation, if
the attachment was removed by the sender here, defendant, it
would delete it from the Discord core servers and then the CDN
cache servers. Back to the video file. I don't know why that's
important, but we'll see. Back to the video file. Solo Tiny Leaks
appears to have obtained it from Rose's Discord account in November
2024.
Thus, the video attachment remained stored on Discord's CDN servers
between April 22nd and November 29th, 2024 and remained accessible
to Rose until it was deleted by defendants sometime after November
29th, 2024. However, it was also publicly accessible via the
permanent link and reachable by index engines between April 9th,
2022 and uh through early December 2023. Although the length
of the permanent URL made it virtually impossible for anyone
to guess it, nevertheless, dissemination and propagation likely
occurred through search index uh search engine indexing. Although
search engines do not index video or audio content itself, it
does index multimedia files metadata which can be rich in information.
As a result, up until nove December 2023, search engine queries
could easily have stumbled upon the video simply by searching
for keywords that match the index metadata. No need to guess
the URL. Therefore, while it is not definitively known if Google
ever indexed the video, it is highly is a highly likely scenario
as seen from the fact that there are confirmed cases of search
engines having indexed content on Discord CDN servers. See below.
So, I'm guessing this will be because the the actual URLs were
put on a different page. Okay, I'm guessing in both of these
cases. Give me a second here. Just reading real quick or sorry,
bring some water real quick. Okay, let me see here. I think we're
going to end on Twitch here, guys. No more Twitch. No more Twitch.
Head over to Head over to kick kick.com/jok
if you're watching on Twitch. Okay, I'll give you guys a second
to get over there and we're going to keep going. All right, I'm
I'm going to end it now. Bye-bye. Click oh. He says no and then
he ends up coming over. What a guy. What a guy. What a guy. Give
me a second. I'm just going to give him a second to switch over,
guys. Okay. All right. All right. All right. Okay. We're good
to go. So, these are the examples of of dis of Discord CDN links
being indexed into Google into some search >> No, it's
not. Stop. You need to demonstrate that. I'm sorry. Okay. I'm
I'm calling I'm calling on that unless you you're able to demonstrate
that to me right now. Okay. You don't even need to use the nudes
or or use any or something. Create some fake file. Okay. Like
some kind of notepad. Okay. Like create create like some random
notepad. All right. And just get to work. Okay. Show me. Show
me that it is possible. Okay. Cuz I refuse to believe this. Okay.
That is being spewed out right now. Okay. Like you have to show
me. Show me that this is able to work. Okay. Stop. You have a
computer. Okay. Show me. All right. I don't have to do it because
the burner proof is not on me. Okay. Do it. Do it now. Okay.
Do it. Show me that the crawler goes over um uh uh Discord attachments
in some like any kind of way. I just show it to you that Zcaler's
threat labs reported that Discord CDN was exploited for malware
distribution with permanent links shared on external platforms,
fishing emails, dark web forums. Some malware files were found
in Google search results indicating indexing. For example, searches
for specific malware file names or URLs surfaced CDN hosted files
as crawlers followed links from public sites. So here's where
you would have to say, okay, where was the URL posted on a public
site so it could be indexed, right? And then I don't even know
like that might be on whoever leaked the file, right? Whoever
sorry, whoever leaked the URL. Trilex noted over 10,000 malware
campaigns using Discord CDN links, some of which were indexed
by Google when shared on index forums or paste sites, eg paste
bin. This included PDFs, images, and executables, not just MP4s.
See this? So you could say,
oh man, this seems like kind of weak, but so again, public sites,
right? So there's no there's no example of a public site where
this happened. There's no proof that it happened. They're just
saying it's possible that it could have been. I don't know. I
don't feel like the law like I only have an intuition there.
I don't feel like the law hits you for that. Right. Where where
you say I don't have any proof that this happened, but I do want
to use it to say that the actual violation of Cardi happened
after
after April 2022. I just I can't see it. But I don't know. Maybe
other people have arguments on this. I'm not sure. In short,
the post October 1st, 2022 ongoing dissemination and accessibility
occurred because the video was not deleted until after November
29th, 2024, and there was an active and permanent URL that pointed
to it through December 2023. Moreover, search engine indexing
crawlers from Google, Bing, and others were known to index the
Discord CDN servers. Uh maybe this argument is enough. I I very
much doubt that this is enough to be taken seriously. If if it
is, Destiny loses automatically.
Um, if if this is taken seriously, this is what I was talking
about when we first looked at this. I thought this argument could
be taken more seriously at the time. I later figured after reading
a little bit more about precedents that it wouldn't. If this
argument was allowed and was allowed to stand and and accepted
by the court, I think I think Destiny is auto losing like he
auto loses at that point. But I I believe they'll strike this
down and say, "No, no, we can't do that." No, it's not that it's
an obscure vulnerability.
So the issue here is that Google can only access the way Google
works is it uses a what what you call a crawler. A crawler looks
at some HTML,
looks at some web page, looks for the HTML, finds all of the
URLs. I'll just give you like a simple example. Finds all of
the URLs on that page, pushes them onto a stack, and then it
just consumes its stack of URLs over time like building out maps
of websites. That's how that's how this worked the whole time.
And that's how like and page rank basically uses the graph there
to to determine what goes to the top of Google. Okay. What makes
it a crawler not a scraper? A scraper is what you would use on
the page to get the information off of the page that you'd want
to index. A crawler is the thing that indexes the UR that that
collects the URLs and then goes and scrapes the individual pages.
So what what the issue here is we have no evidence that a crawler
that that builds up these uh lists of URLs that get featured
on Google on any search engine. Yeah. Crawler makes the map.
Yep. So um the the crawler wouldn't have had access to this URL
and there's no proof it had access to this URL
unless
some public website that was already crawling had the URL put
on it. I don't know that there's any evidence that that happened.
And the possibility that it happened is probably not enough to
say that you can go back in time and say, well, that April 1st
or April 9th, April 10th, 2022 violation actually comes forward
now to to October 1st. I just I think that probably doesn't work.
Destiny made a claim that it's impossible to index attachments
in DMs. I think they're just trying to say he's wrong, that it's
impossible. So, it's they're saying no, it's possible to do that
if the URL is posted somewhere publicly.
And I don't I I mean, I just don't take that as a meaning when
Desi says in DMs, but that's just me. Anyway, in conclusion,
by defendant's own admission, he used Discord to send the video
to Rose as an attachment. There were no protective measures in
place to safeguard his and the plaintiff's privacy such as one
the platform used to send the video would encrypt while transmitting.
Two, the platform would store attachments in an encrypted state
and require authentication or three recipient would give assurances
that it was would be safeguarded. The discord vulnerability related
to the attachments being publicly available should have been
considered by the defendant as it was a known issue in the discord
community for an entire year before defendant sent the video.
video remained active and accessible to the public until December
2023 when Discord converted to temporary links. But by that time,
Cardi had been in effect for 13 months. I mean, it's possible.
It's possible that this goes through. I think it would be not
in the spirit of the law necessarily,
but it's it's sort of like a narrow it's a narrow it's a more
narrow thing here. I don't think this would mean all. They're
basically handing some precedent that could be set by this court
that wouldn't involve all previous attachments ever sent by anybody
ever. They're saying, "Well, with this specific Discord thing,
it could have gone to search engines. It could have done, right?"
Which is, I guess, interesting. Um, there's probably some philosophy
on how law works that would explain exactly like how likely this
is to succeed. I'm not totally sure. I'm still like 95% no, 5%
yes, maybe 99% no, but not 100% yet or I I guess I've been pushed
back from 100%. Uh, moreover, the video remained accessible to
Rose and anyone who had access to Rose's Discord account, i.e.
Solo Tiny Leaks, until after November 29th, 2024 when defendant
finally deleted it. The defendant's evidence mismanagement and
consequent unreliability.
A review of the pleadings and materials would indicate that the
defendant's ESI was not collected and preserved. This is electronically
stored information was not collected and preserved in a forensically
sound manner. This failure constitutes a critical deficiency
as the foundational principle of digital digital forensics dictates
that cryptographic hash values must be generated at the time
of collection to ensure the integrity and authenticity of the
data. Without these unique digital identifiers, there is no reliable
method to determine if the data set has been altered or compromised
at any point after its initial collection. This principle is
the cornerstone of digital forensics practice. Yeah. So you create
a unique hash for all the files and probably the collection of
files, right?
Like some some like file tree or something to say this is what
it is and anybody who hands you a file that doesn't m match these
hashes like uh that that that's been modified. That makes total
sense to me. This principle is the cornerstone of digital forensics
practice. For comparison reference, the plaintiff's acquisition
log of her mobile phone, which includes the requisite cryptographic
hash values, is attached here to as exhibit B. The defendant's
mismanagement renders the production entirely unreliable as it
cannot be authenticated if asked to reproduce findings from it.
Simply put, there is no way to run a cryptographic algorithm
that will assure the data was not altered after being preserved
because there is no value to compare it to. Thus, the defendant's
evidence is not reliable and cannot be authenticated. Yeah, that
makes total sense. Now, they're going to be on the other side
of like, will judges understand why that's important? Who knows?
This is basically saying that like, how do I put this for people
so they understand it? Um, you can basically for any computer
file create a specific fingerprint for it, right? That if any
one or zero in that file changes, you basically get a new like
a different fingerprint.
You can create this unique fingerprint and then what it's saying
is all files or all lines of logs that were ever preserved from
this should have some hash with them to say whether or not that
thing has been like altered after the fact. And not and with
Destiny here, not only is there no way to to make sure it hasn't
been tampered with, it's kind of been admittedly tampered with,
right? Like there's evidence of these things being tampered with.
Got here late. What the [__] is wrong with my notifications?
That's unfortunate, but welcome, welcome, welcome. All right.
Bulliation. There is significant evidence of apparent document
tampering related to defendants's document production and to
his evidence submitted in support of his motion to dismiss. The
first instance relates to an excerpt of Discord messages from
defendants Discord account Bates SB00001690
which was prepared after January 17th, 2025 and the corresponding
messages taken from a screenshot taken well before January 17th,
2025 from an account belonging to a Discord user Rose Bates.
I don't know what these references are, but see below direct
messages Rose uh girl once. I love it. Oh my god. All this stuff.
And then these are the screenshots here. I'd love it. OMG. This
is 8:33.
133 128
28. I thought one of these time stamps was off, but he's circling
these things. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. In theory, had both conversations
been collected at the same time, the content would be identical.
However, that was not the case, and the version from Defended
Side is conspicuously missing the video attachment that was originally
sent by Defendant on April 9th, 2022, 8:36 p.m. Eastern or April
10th, 2022, 1:36 a.m. UTC. However, pursuant pursuant to defendant's
declaration of April 25th, 2025 ECF421
upon plaintiff's request, defendant removed the video presumably
from the Discord chat message to Rose in late November 2024.
Which explains why it is missing from defendants's chat history.
See below. Oh, he's being like good faith. He's saying, well,
the video the attachment is gone, right? But that uh we basically
agreed that Pixie asked you to remove it and that's probably
why this discrepancy exists. Okay. Uh, from defendant defendants
production, Bates SB00.
Okay.
Should be between 8:33 p.m. and 8:39 p.m. messages. Posting of
the video removed from defendants production, which was at plaintiff's
request. Okay, that all makes sense. So, that would mean
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. All right. Good enough. Good enough.
There's an apparent sign of tampering seen in defendants 49 2022
8:33 p.m. Message from Rose wherein she comments to have viewed
the video. April 9th, 2025, 8:33 p.m. before it doc its documented
arrival at April 9th, 8:36 p.m., which is physically impossible.
It does not appear that Rose somehow came back and edited the
8:33 p.m. message after viewing the video. The only way to update
a message from a Discord user is for the owner to delete it or
edit it, in which case an edit would have been edited. Uh, an
edit would have edited appended to the message, and no qualifier
is seen. No such qualifier is seen. This temporal and logical
inconsistency serves as an apparent indication of post Discord
export manipulation.
Oh, damn. Uh-oh. So, hold on. So, this happens at 36. I'd love
it. Oh my god, that was amazing. I can't wait to blow you now.
Is right here before 8:39 p.m. Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. How long does Discord wait to group messages?
Cuz this is like grouped right here, right? It's grouped under
the same time stamp. So, there should be some message after
and it's saying 8:33,
but there's probably some unique time stamp to this message,
right? Document arrival at 8:36. Uh,
so to me, what this probably means is the this is probably why
you shouldn't use Discord message exporter, right? Or whatever.
you probably should use something
that is for digital forensics because it's not indexing the individual
messages and saving all of the metadata for all the individual
messages, right? It's producing it's reproducing a Discord like
looking chat.
And so, yes, these things are probably grouped together because
they're close enough in time, but I don't know that you have
any guarantee that these wouldn't be grouped together. So, hold
on. When um when does Discord stop grouping messages under the
same time stamp? New cut off time for separating messages six
years ago. So
7 minutes. 7 minutes is a reference. I don't know if that's what
it was now, but it would be before basically if this came within
7 minutes, there's a reason why that this would exist in this
order, right? So there should be and Destiny should have produced
the messages individually. And guess what? Pixie did that, right?
I think isn't that why Destiny so is every message for Pixie
is a different file. I think that's like why he was so mad, right?
Yeah, exactly. Neosc Yes. And then it is 7 minutes from the first
or the latest message. So the first So this one. So probably
what what you what it used to look like was there was the separation
here of this video getting posted, right? And then within some
period of time, she responds with uh with this. Yeah. And we
know it's before the seven-minute cut off because Destiny has
a message before the seven-minute cut off, including the extra
messages in his own version actually worked against him here.
Yeah. I I just think that that's funny that like this is probably
why you you save each individual message in like a like an Excel
file or something like some spreadsheet because you want all
of the you want all of the metadata there, right? Anyway, there's
an apparent sign of tampering seen in defendants's April 9th,
2022, 8:33 p.m. Message from Rose wherein she comments to have
viewed the video. Oh, we read this. We read this. We read this.
So, moreover, the defendant relied on these same chat excerpts
in his motion to dismiss page 9. C also exhibits A and B to Benel
declaration ECF 132 1322
132 3 revealing the same inconsistency. 132
23. So there's this guy's two, this guy is three. So he's got
the same 1:33 p.m. 1:36 a.m. thing going on here. And then
that was amazing. Can't wait. And we have the same grouping here.
Okay. All right. Interesting. Right here. The defendant relied
on a comparison of these two documents is the sole support for
his assertion that the evidence conclusively establishes that
the video was transmitted on April 9th, 2022 at 8:36 p.m. Eastern.
ECF32, page 9. Yet, the Discord chat thread ECF1322
does not show any transmission of the video at 8:36 p.m. and
also appears to have been tampered with and is thus not reliable
as evidence. Oh, dude. I didn't even I didn't pick this up, man.
Imagine what level of a you need to be to look at all of those
messages and say, "Oh, no, no. You You're not proving this at
all. You explain what's new. What's new?" Um, they're going to
mention that Rose was a minor. They're going to mention that
they have subpoenaed Rose. That's coming up, though. Spoilers.
Um, and what's new? They have a We're reading through a forensics
expert, a digital forensics expert kind of shredding Destiny's
evidence he used in his motion to dismiss,
explaining where all the inconsistencies are, all of the um all
the unresolved questions. But I guarantee you somewhere I I feel
like somewhere Destiny's got an export of that message that has
the time stamp 8:36 p.m. and it's just not included here for
some reason. Oh, what's up, wind? Uh, why does Rose's age matter
in this case? This guy, this storming wind guy is um somebody
from Destiny's like core group chat and that if you're wondering
why he would come and ask that question. He's gonna he's going
to try to do this is very funny. Um why would it matter in this
case? I might give some argument if Pixie wants to make arguments
along the lines of well Destiny said he got a private investigator
to go find this person, but obviously given that she was a minor,
he probably didn't look too hard, right? if she if she wants
to do stuff like that to show he's like unreliable.
Um there's probably some amount of like I think she has what
distress claims like uh mental distress claims of some kind and
those could be exacerbated uh with regards to like the punitive
damages. So I would assume that it feels a little different thinking
your nudes have been used to become to somebody else and then
learning that they're actually used to groom a minor, right?
Like that's
that that's probably like a different level of distress. Could
be something along those lines. Destiny also claimed he knew
Rose well. Yeah. Also shows him as inconsistent that he'll lie
when giving his deposition or giving his sworn statements. Yeah.
So I I think there's a couple reasons you could include it. Yeah.
And probably I would imagine it also it also probably makes sense
why Destiny has never tried to subpoena this person, right? Even
though they could provide the testimony as the judge hinted at.
He said, "Oh, obviously you'd want to subpoena this person, depose
them, and get their testimony on when these messages came in."
But there's a reason. Probably Destiny and Mr. Breler didn't
pursue that strategy. Okay.
All right. Continuing, continuing, continuing. Conclusively establishes
the video is transmitted here, but it doesn't do that
and it seems to be tampered with. The second spoilation issue
noted is with exhibit E of the motion to dismiss ECF-132-6
where in defendant appears to have manually transposed content
from a Discord chat with screen name in Bloom 1991. The timestamps
and Google Drive file ident uh Google file identifiers Google
Drive file identifiers in the URLs from the chat history do not
match the same from the list of the defendants prepared uh prepared
of media files sent to Discord screen name ABMC see below. Oh,
it's like in the wrong order or something. Oh, I see. I see.
I see. So, this is going to be that he used like OCR to to get
these URLs and put them in his Excel document. And if he'd manually
typed them out, he would never have made this mistake. And now
he's going to say, "Well, this isn't just trans. This isn't just
like produced from some evidence file. This is him like doing
things in the background. This is him like editing things." So,
not good. Not good. Yeah. Here's the the missing slash after
the fact. Oh, boy. Oh, boy. Uh, no slash here, right? The URLs
have been edited in some way. They're not just being like transposed.
They're not just being copy pasted over from some evidence thing.
Okay, there is more evidence of tampering. The two Google Drive
links that Banell reportedly sent to both Abby ECF132-6
and Peach ECF132-7
in the two chat threads are actually not the same links. The
highlighted links below are from ECF132-7
and the non- highlighted links are from
So again, just highlighting the missing. The highlighted URL
has ZHR31
lowercase 1 and the bottom has ZHR31
number one. Oh, huh. A lowercase L. And the bottom one has ZHR31
number one. Also, the highlighted URL ends in WBT/ view question
mark. And the bottom one ends in WBV view question mark. The
I didn't do the slash here. Okay. The highlighted link begins
with 1K and the other one from ECF132-7
is LK or L_K.
Also, oh, god damn it. Also, the highlighted link has L8-
N L or one starting with lowercase L. Bottom link uh starts with
a one and a space or underscore after the N. So,
we can just see a couple of these things right here, right? We
see the differences here. See the differences? So, like realistically,
I don't I don't know if this like changes the argument he's making,
but they're saying that none of this is really going to be admissible
or proof of or solid evidence because it's obviously been edited.
He's manually changed things. It is it doesn't have like a clean
what do you call it? Like a clean chain of custody kind of thing
like that you would use hashes for. You you use hashes to maintain
a chain of custody or or maintain sanctity of evidence in a digital
case, right? And that's not been done here. And it's obviously
been edited. It's not even He can't even argue it was just transposed
like or trans transferred over like one to one. Can't even argue
it because it's clearly been edited. Unlike uh Yeah. Unlucky.
Very unlucky. Okay. Uh, thus the above evidence which was relied
on by defendant in his motion to dismiss for his assertion that
his preserved communication logs with ABMC conclusively established
that he never transmitted the video to her at any time ECF-132
page 13 is not reliable evidence because it appears to have been
tampered with. Finally, I note the following. Benell states that
the original file name of the video as revealed by Solo Tiny
Leaks CECF132-5
is not the same as either of the file names that he sent to ABMC
T1326.
That proves that he never sent the video to ABMC. Motions uh
pages 13 to 14. But Banell is comparing apples to oranges because
the two file names in ECF132-6
that he puredly sent to ABMC on November 3rd, 2023 are not file
names. Instead, they are Google Drive link URLs which merely
point to an unknown file name to unknown file names under penalties
of perjury. So, he literally could have moved this within his
drive. He could have sent a different drive link. He could have
like permissions set up in a different way. They could be the
same file with different URLs, right? They totally could be.
That's what he's arguing. Instead, they're Google Drive link
URLs which merely point to unknown file names. Under penalties
of perjury, I declare that I have read the foregoing document
and that the facts stated in it are true to the best of my knowledge
and belief.
October 3rd, 2025. Jesus Pena
A, this is his like CV basically. And then he's got some citations
here. And what these would be is from like taking stuff off of
Pixie's device showing how he would do this. Okay. He's got like
a bunch of things in here. Jesus. Okay. All right. I don't think
any of those are too relevant. Like they're um I I think mostly
stuff that I knew the veracity of to begin with. Okay. Now, this
last claim. So Destiny claims that the original file because
the original file name file name of the video as revealed by
Solo Tiny Leaks, it is the same as is not the same as either
the file names that he sent to ABMC.
That proves that he never sent the video to ABMC. But Banell
is comparing apples to oranges because the two file names in
that he purportedly sent to ABMC on November 3rd, 2023 are not
file names. Instead, they are Google Drive link URLs which merely
point to unknown file names. So
there are these. He's saying that these two Google Drive links,
what he's saying is he sent this stuff to ABMC and he's saying
for these two Google Drive links I sent to ABMC. Here is another
person. Well, I sent those same Google Drive links too. Now,
the Google Drive links have been edited. I think I think this
has been sort of um put into the realm of questionable because
of the clear edits.
But the argument Desty's making is that
I hear somebody talking about the files that I sent to someone
else who's like going to give me a statement. I think this is
Peach and Peach gave him a statement about when when those files
were created or who they were with or some [__] Yeah.
Okay. So, we we just went and covered the the digital forensics
expert, right? And basically what he would like to do here, what
he thinks the the issues are with Destiny's testimony. And I
think he threw a couple things into question that probably should
be examined. There's a lot of reason to believe Destiny tampered
with evidence through incompetence rather than
um intentionally.
right? Like he could tamper with evidence intentionally, but
it's it seems obvious that this tampering is like through incompetence,
but it does thrown to I I think it provides like questionability
of the evidence in general. So that's why I think it basically
you wouldn't dismiss yet because you have like material disputes
of fact that haven't been conclusively disproven or conclusively
set in stone one way or another, right? like he failed to do
that because of the incompetence in preserving stuff and because
of the inconsistencies pointed out by the digital forensics expert.
Yeah. Yep. Anyway, where are we going here? What are we looking
for? Oh, we're back to this. We're back to not Wait, I had a
page. I had a page. Here we go. Here we go. Here's where we were.
That where we were. Let me close. Let me close to make sure.
That was where we were. Okay. All right. Okay, I thought we were
lower than this, but so we read through defendants factual challenge
must be denied because of uh the jurisdiction and merits are
intertwined and then defendants factual challenge is premature
as in discovery hasn't finished. I think we read this entire
thing. Yeah, we definitely did. Alternatively, there are material
issues of fact in dispute that prevent summary judgment. Alternatively,
even if the court were to convert Benell's rule 12b1 motion into
a motion for summary judgement and not defer ruling until after
discovery is complete, the motion should be denied because there
are genuine issues of material fact. A genuine dispute of material
fact exists if evidence is such that a reasonable jury could
return a verdict for the non-movement. Okay. Anderson v is the
source for this president. The court must view the evidence and
all reasonable inferences drawn from the evidence in the light
most favorable to the non-movement. judgment may be inappropriate
even when both parties agree on the basic facts but disagree
about the factual inferences that should be drawn from these
facts. If reasonable minds might differ on the inferences arising
from disputed facts, then the court should deny summary judgement.
Defendants's motion. Um, okay, that seems reasonable. Uh, a defendant's
motion must be denied because it rests on tainted and inadmissible
evidence. At the outset, plaintiff objects to defendants's reliance
on exhibits B, C, DD, E, and F to BL's declarations ECF 132 34567
under FC FRCP 56C2
because these materials cannot be presented in a form that would
be admissible in evidence based on all material and communications
produced by the defendant, including these exhibits. He embarked
on a DIY search to preserve, authenticate, and produce documents,
but failed to adhere to the cornerstone principle of digital
forensics, forensically sound data preservation. Specifically,
the essential step of generating cryptographic hash values at
the time of collection was omitted. T decoration J Pa exhibit
A paragraph 16. These hashes are unique digital identifiers that
ensure integrity without initial hash value to compare against
any subsequent analysis or attempt to reproduce findings is based
on unauthenticated
and unreliable data. The defendants's mismanagement of ESI effectively
breaks the chain of custody, preventing any reliable verification
that the evidence remains in its original state. I mean, this
is definitely true. I don't know if that means it's not presentable.
Um,
it's definitely true and it's probably, you know, doubles in
concern given that it's clear it was manipulated or tampered
with. We'll see. I don't know. I don't know how they handle this.
We'll see how they handle it. Moreover, the documents bear indication
of alteration and tampering and cannot be properly authenticated
under FRCP or no sorry not civil procedure federal rule of evidence
901 uh from the expert declaration. Such tampering constitutes
bulliation and at minimum creates a genuine issue of material
fact as to the reliability of defendant submissions where credibility
and authenticity are in dispute. Summary judgment is inappropriate
because credibility determinations, the weighing of evidence
and the drawing of legitimate inferences from the facts are jury
functions, not those of a judge. That might be the part. So that
I don't know why they have this so low in their arguments. That
seems like probably the better point to me is you can point to
how unreliable how how noncredible Destiny is as a fact witness,
right? He lied to Pixie about knowing Rose. He lied about knowing
like a bunch of stuff about Rose, right? He lied about thinking
she was in the UK. There's like there's like things where he's
he's twisted stuff to like try to paint different narratives.
And I think I think there are like arguments you can make there
that he's not credible as a source of this information at all.
So, but maybe maybe that's just a difficult argument to make.
It's possible that that's just a really difficult argument to
make and like judges probably don't like they might not listen
to that argument ever essentially unless you have them essentially
like on tape saying that they're going to lie to a jury or a
judge. Like you might need something that obvious. There are
disputed issues of fact. So B, there are disputed issues of fact
regarding Bedell's disclosure to Rose and whether it was within
the ambit of Cardi. The Venant claims that the disclosure of
the video of to Rose fails to establish subject matter jurisdiction
because one, it occurred prior to October 1st, 2022, and two,
the continuous accessibility theory fails as a matter of law.
Both of these arguments fail. The court has already determined
the defendant's evidence regarding the disclosure to Rose is
murky at best. None of the evidence presented in defendants's
motion regarding the timing of his disclosure to Rose is new.
The same evidence has been presented to the court numerous times.
See ECF42109.
Indeed, the court has already reviewed this this same evidence
and held that the evidence establishing a definitive timeline
as to what defendant did or did not do and when is murky at best.
ECF-18, page 8. Opinion and order granting plaintiff's motion
for leave to file amended complaint. Emphasis supplied. The court
also noted that noticeably absent from the defendant's arguments
generally regarding subject matter jurisdiction is testimony
from Rose that would corroborate defendants's characterization
that incorporates in exhibit C a screenshot from Rose's Discord
account. Uh
see previously cited emphasis in original. Despite this clear
directive from the court, defendant failed to submit any corroborating
evidence from Rose and instead simply submitted the same evidence
and arguments that the court already rejected. Thus there is
no need for the court to revisit this issue. On this basis alone
the court can deny the motion. Okay. There are disputed issues
of fact regarding the date of disclosure to rose. Defendant relies
on comparison of two documents ECF 1322 1323 as the sole support
for his assertion that the evidence conclusively establishes
that the video was transmitted on April 9th, 2022 at 8:36 p.m.
Eastern. Motion page 9. Yet, the Discord chat thread ECF-1322
does not show any transmission of the video at 1:36 p.m. and
it actually contradicts that contention. Moreover, the chat thread
shows signs of tampering and is thus not reliable evidence. In
the Discord chat thread, 1:32, Banell offers to send Rose the
video at 8:28 p.m. Then at 8:33 p.m., Rose responds, "I'd love
it. OMG." Immediately followed by, "That was amazing. I can't
wait to blow you now." And yet in the leaked screenshot 1323
and according to Banell's declaration of the motion, the video
was not sent to Rose until 8:36 p.m. Rose could not have been
responding that the video was amazing at 8:33 p.m. if she did
not receive the video until 8:36 p.m. This temporal and logical
inconsistency is an indication of post Discord manipulation.
See exhibit A declaration J. Pena Jesus Pña at pages 17 to 18.
Thus, this evidence should not be considered by the court. Moreover,
it certainly does not conclusively establish that Benell sent
the video to Rose on April 9th, 2022. Hold on, I missed a I missed
a little thing here. Okay, this is this is the juicy one. Okay,
despite this clear directive from the court, defendant failed
to submit any corroborating evidence from Rose and instead simply
submitted the same evidence to the court that the court had already
rejected. So, even though the court went, hey, you could just
you could just ask Rose and this person could tell you like what
there's they just give you the other side of the story, right?
And Destiny goes, no, no, no, no. I'm uh I'm going to just give
I'm not going to do that. Why would I do that? And I think Pixie's
team Pixie's team might have some, you know, some thoughts on
why they did that. In fact, it is plaintiff, not defendant, that
has made efforts to obtain evidence from Rose. Plaintiff hired
a private investigator to ascertain Rose's legal identity and
location, and has just this week managed to serve Rose with a
subpoena. Do you say Techum? Deuces Techum? I don't know. And
to appear at a deposition. So Rose has been served to be deposed.
Cool. After finally ascertaining Rose's legal identity, plaintiff
has obtained evidence that Rose's date of birth is October 30th,
2004. Thus, when Banell was exchanging content with Rose between
March 2 March of 2022 and until October 20 30th, 2022, Rose was
a minor. See exhibit B here too. Redacted official certification
of Department of Motor Vehicles driving record. Damn.
Damn. Oh, I forgot. Another reason to include that she's a minor
is to inform the court that any that includes her before this
date is inadmissible as evidence, right? Any any evidence that
Destiny has to remove, I believe that that is expoliation and
it will count against him in the case. At least that's what a
potentially criminal said. That's one of the lawyers that's looking
at this. So, right. So, you say, "Hey, all of this stuff on Rose's
side, that's actually inadmissible. you you can't submit child
evidence
and then the deleted files which if he archived all of this stuff,
right? The deleted files should show up in that archive, the
the file names at least. And there'll be no way to to know for
sure whether or not uh Pixie's referenced in those files. It'll
have to be, you know, used against
against him. That's that's what I heard. Okay. I don't know if
that's real, but that's that's what the lawyer said. Okay. Okay.
So, we got Okay. There are also contradictions in Bedell's declaration
submitted to the court about the date of his disclosure to rose
in Bedell's April 25th, 2025 declaration
He claimed under penalty of perjury that the reason the leaked
screenshot had a European date stamp is because it is a screenshot
from Rose's side of the conversation and Rose was corresponding
from a time zone 5 hours ahead of me in Miami, Florida. ECF 421,
paragraph 9, emphasis supplied. See also ECF42,
page 14. The date is reflected using the European time for date
time format day, month, year because Rose was communicating with
Benel from a European time zone. Oh, that's not great. Yeah,
not good. When then it later comes out that Destiny supplied
the college major and multiple photos of this person to Kiwi
Farms directly said, "Hey, Kiwi Farms, you guys suck. You can't
find this person." Right? That it certainly seems like he knew
exactly where she was from and where she went to school. So,
it's kind of weird that that would get thrown in a declaration,
but okay. Defendant now claims without providing any explanation
for his directly contradictory assertions that it was not Rose
that was in Europe at the time of this the disclosure, but rather
it was Solo Tiny Leaks who was located in Europe at the time
he accessed the video and other material from Rose's Discord
account such that the timestamps are reflected in the standard
European time format. Motion page 8. Banell provides no evidence
to support his new contradictory assertion that Solo Tiny Leaks
was in Europe. Thus, Benell's explanation for the different timestamps
is nothing other than sheer speculation.
Accordingly, there are disputed factual issues regarding the
date of Benell's disclosure to Rose and the defendant's motion
can be denied on the spaces alone. The evidence and legal precedent
established that Banell's disclosure to Rose made the video accessible
after October 1st, 2022.
Even assuming that Banell's initial disclosure of the video to
Rose occurred before October 1st, 2022, this has not been established.
His disclosure made the video accessible after October 1st, 2022.
The Cardi statute provides a right of action to an individual
whose intimate image uh intimate visual depiction is disclosed
without the consent of the individual. 15 USC 6851 B1A emphasis
provided. Cardi defines disclose as to transfer, publish, distribute,
or make accessible. 15 USC 6851 A4. Emphasis provided. This is
a broad definition. Uh and they give this case. I'm guessing
I'm guessing this case is weak. Whatever this one is. I I I'll
think about looking this one up after. Hold on. Give me a second.
I'll put like a DM somewhere. Okay. Maybe we'll look at that
one after. All right. Although Cardi is a relatively new statute
and there's little case law interpreting it, at least one court
has upheld a continuous disclosure argument. See dov unknown
party from this time 2024 pocket in Arizona. The DO court found
that although the initial disclosure of the certain of certain
videos was done before the effective date of Cardi, there is
a colorable colorable argument that defendant continued to disclose
the recordings after the statute's effective date because he
allegedly continued to make those videos accessible on the internet
until after the effective date. So even if Banell's initial transfer
of the video to Rose took place before the effective date of
Cardi, as defendant contends, because Banel's disclosure made
the video accessible after the effective date, it is within the
statutory definition.
And here it is indisputable that the video was accessible to
Rose after the effective date because otherwise Solo Tiny Leaks
would not have been able to access the video from Rose in November
2024. Uh in addition to being made accessible to Rose and Solo
Tiny Leaks after October 1st, 2022, it was also made accessible
to the public as fully detailed in the declaration of plaintiffs
forensics expert Mr. Jus Pña.
At this early stage of discovery and based on the current evidence,
it appears the video was sent to Rose via an attachment on Discord.
Declaration J Pena exhibit A paragraph 13. The video remained
stored on Discord's content delivery network and remained accessible
to Rose until it was finally deleted by defendant after the November
24th 29th, 2024 Kiwi Farms post by Solotai Leaks as the Pena
declaration again. Moreover, the video was also publicly accessible
via the permanent link and reachable by index engines between
April 9th, 2022 through early December 2023.
This unprotected, unrestricted accessibility of the video is
due to a significant security issue in how Discord implemented
storage and access of message attachments on its CDN servers
that cache Discord's attachments. Between April 22nd, 2021, and
up until sometime in December 2023, when Discord security issue
was finally rectified, all attachments sent in messages were
permanently publicly accessible from the CDN servers simply by
navigating to a permanent web address that pointed to the attachment.
Moreover, the contrary Moreover, and contrary to defendant's
assertion that Discord attachments were not publicly indexable,
indexed, or searchable, motion FN4,
search engine indexing crawlers from Google, Bing, and others
did index the Discord CDN servers. It is important to note that
Banell could have deleted the video attachment at any time prior
to November 29th, 2024, in which case it would not have been
accessible to Rose, Solo Tiny Leaks, or the public, but he did
not do so. Defendant's argument that the continuing accessibility
theory fails as a matter of law is premised on two factual contentions.
One, the Discord attachment was a one-time file attachment. And
two, the attachment was not publicly indexed nor searchable.
Motions
uh paragraph 112 and FN4 as set forth above and further detailed
in Mr. Pena's declaration. Both of these contentions are erroneous.
Huh.
I wonder if at some point if it let's say it were hypothetically
without realizing it was actually indexed. Let's say hypothetically
it was indexed because of the update there might be no record
of that, right? Am I crazy? I think because of the update there
may actually be no record of that file ever being
um being there because the URL would stop working. So it would
just be removed. It would be pruned. I don't know if they keep
like a record of all URLs that have ever been stored in like
the in the indexes, right? No, no, no. The update would make
it 404. The update would make it 404. So, it may not be held
in any like you would never know. You may never know. So, that
is that seems to be like a that that is interesting.
Might be worth looking into at some point. So, basically Oh,
man. is the idea that it could be does that change
the like the legal analysis that happened in in the case they're
referencing here? I don't know. I don't know, man. Well, if everything
before was indexed, then it would have also been until it was
fixed. No, no, no. Not everything was indexed two legs. Everything
that was indexed had to be indexed off of public publicly uh
crawable search or crawl public publicly crawable URLs or websites
and the URL would have to be posted on those websites and then
it could be stored. There's no there's no reason to think Discord
CDN links couldn't be stored in
um in like a search index,
but they only persisted for like a year and a half or something.
There was a time where they automatically persisted. So, the
argument would be it was posted somewhere publicly. It could
have been accessed, stored, indexed, and be publicly available
based on some metadata in it, right? But I don't know, man. It's
like I I think that's like such a low possibility. I don't know
if that means anything. Anemone, the largest Cassandra database
instance. Um, also I'm not saying it wouldn't be stored on Discord.
It was still stored with Discord. Almost certainly, it just wasn't
in the search index, the publicly available search index. So,
see whether or not Defendant disclosed the video to ABMC is there
disputed issue of fact preventing summary judgment. Even assuming
arguo that the disclosure to Rose, what does this mean? Arguendo,
huh? For the sake of argument. Okay. Even assuming argu though
that the disclosure to Rose was before October 1st 2022 and that
the disclosure did not make the video continuously accessible
after October 1st 2022 subject matter jurisdiction can still
be found based on Benel's disclosure to ABMC after October 1st
2022. Viewing the facts and evidence in light most favorable
to plaintiff the evidence establishes that Banell did transmit
the video to ABMC or at the very least that this is a disputed
issue of fact requiring further discovery and preventing submarine
judgment. Moreover, the evidence submitted and relied on by Benell
for his assertion that he never sent the video to ABMC appears
to have been tampered with and is thus and thus is unreliable
and inadmissible. I do wonder how many times you can show that
the evidence has been modified before you like stop being looked
at as something somebody who could be reliable, right? Banel
fails to establish that he never transmitted the video to ABMC.
Banel claims I mean obviously this is true. Banel claims that
he preserved communication logs with ABMC conclusively estab
uh that oh sorry Benell claims that his preserved communication
logs with ABMC conclusively established that he never transmitted
the video to her at any time. ECF32 page 13 but the uh but these
preserved communication logs are nothing other than an Excel
spreadsheet purportedly including all media files sent to ABMC
created by the defendant for the purpose of his motion as well
as a purported chat thread between him and ABMC in Bloom 1991.
Wait, isn't this Peach? Am I crazy? I thought this was Peach.
I I think this is Am I Am I misunderstanding? I thought the whole
point of it was that this was Peach and these were the the attachments
he sent to Peach or something. In Bloom 1991 is Abby. Oh, that
I misunderstood a previous piece of this. There were inconsistencies
between those. Okay. Okay. Sure, sure. Sure. Yeah, it's fine.
It's fine. I just I misunderstood. I thought they were doing
the comparison of the Google Drive links between the Peach logs
and the Abby logs. He does do that. as far as I'm con as far
as I'm aware, but it wasn't what they were referencing in the
PA in the PA piece.
preserved logs might have consisted of a copy of his Discord
exports in an HTML file, but instead this is merely evidence
artificially created by Banell. There's no way to verify whether
the list of media files sent to ABMC is complete or accurate.
Therefore, the evidence should be disregarded. The evidence presented
in ECF132-6
should also be disregarded because one, it is inconsistent, and
two, there's evidence of foliation. A comparison of the time
stamps and Google Drive file identifiers in the two URLs from
the chat thread do not match the same from the spreadsheet list
the defendant prepared of media files sent to AB uh ABMC. See,
uh, PA exhibit A, paragraph 19. Hold on, I need to reopen that.
Give me a second. Me, let me grab this PA declaration again.
between the peach logs and the abbey logs. He does do that as
far as I'm as far as I'm aware, but it wasn't what they were
referencing in the PA in the PA piece. CCF1326
preserved logs might have consisted of a copy of his Discord
exports in an HTML file. But instead, this is merely evidence
artificially created by Benell. There's no way to verify whether
the list of media files sent to ABMC is complete or accurate.
Therefore, the evidence should be disregarded. The evidence presented
in ECF-132-6
should also be disregarded because one, it is inconsistent, and
two, there's evidence of spiliation. A comparison of the time
stamps in Google Drive file identifiers in the two URLs from
the chat thread do not match the same from the spreadsheet list.
The defendant prepared of media files sent to AB ABMC. See, uh,
PA exhibit A, paragraph 19. Hold on, I need to reopen that. Give
me a second. Let me let me grab this PA declaration again.
Hold on, let me pull this up. Paragraph 19
or eastern part of this
14. Oh, why is there a 10-hour difference there? That's weird.
I see the I see the inconsistency, though. They're saying the
um the hours are different. Okay, sure, sure, sure.
>> Okay. Because of this inconsistency, the evidence does
not support defendants's argument. This inconsistency also indicates
that the evidence has been tampered with and thus it cannot be
considered by the court. There is more evidence of tampering.
The two Google Drive links that Banell purportedly sent to both
Abby and Peach in the two chat threads are not actually the same
are actually not the same links. See PA declaration paragraph
20 demonstrating the myriad differences between the links. Thus,
defendants's contention that the videos he sent to ABMC were
the same videos he sent to Peach and were allegedly videos of
Peach and not a plaintiff is unsupported. Further evidence of
fabiliation is Benell's admission on a live stream on September
8th, 2025 that these preserved communication logs were artificially
created by him. Information is lost. There is no original file.
I'm trying to reconstruct a file. I'm artificially creating a
file by reconstructing a log of stuff. And that's what I'm trying
to do. And it's not working.
Bro, why do you why would you say this? This is so >> Uh
content creators who quote challenged Kla Harris, but she's >> Are
you okay? Jesus Christ. What's going >> No, I'm not okay.
I'm not okay. It's not. It's not working. I don't know why the
messages are not working, dude. Jesus Christ. >> I have
two different files that I'm trying to combine into a singular
file, but I don't know how any of these files are exporting their
dates. I can't
you can import
the world using literally import CSVs.
You can import CSVs into another CSV. It's not hard. >> I
don't know. I don't know how it's getting the time for any of
it though. I don't know what with respect to what because it
should all just it should all just do it in Unix time codes,
but it doesn't. And sometimes it does it in a with respect to
when you export. Sometimes it does it with respect to when the
program exported it 12 years ago and then it converts it to some
other time stamp and the Unix time code is lost and it did a
time zone conversion.
You can drag and drop and convert to Unix. Like it's not that
hard. I don't understand
information is lost. I can't tell. I don't know what the actual
code is. >> You then you have the original files. You can
just like recombine it. Like there is no original file. I'm trying
to reconstruct the file. I'm artificially creating a file by
reconstructing a a log of stuff. That's what I'm trying to do
and it's not working. >> But you could just like dude,
you can
>> I would also think if you're if you're trying to do
something to submit as evidence and it is like synthetically
created, should that not be like expressed somewhere? Should
that not be documented somewhere, right? To say like this is
not a file exported by anything. This is something I hacked together
using a chat GPT script that I that I generated. Like, shouldn't
that be a part of the I mean, he's using chat GPT to make a script
that's supposed to convert these things, combine them together,
right? That's what's happening. I just But but like I feel like
he should just have to express to the judge like when you submit
it, he could say, "Okay, I have like these these totally disconnected
things that were exported from different places. I'm trying to
put them together into the same thing so I can show them on one
screen for you." I feel like you should I feel like you should
say that to the judge and explain the source of the two things
and include the source things so that they can be verified by
like a digital forensics expert. But anyway, >> oh my god,
you okay? I'm pretty just need to stare at it and eventually
we'll
>> Oh my god. >> Uh remember the the written house
case? There was an argument the upscaling of the image with digital
zoom is uh is creation and could influence is a creation and
could influence the jury so it shouldn't be admitted. I remember
that argument about uh the what what was it? Uncharged pickles.
Is that what the judge said? David Pacman uses that as a soundboard.
Uncharged pickles. He couldn't he couldn't say pixels. He just
kept saying pickles over and over again. >> Oh my god.
Just pay somebody to to program it for you. Hold on. Radiant
wants to help. Who's Radiant? Who's this guy? Look. Do you listen?
>> Okay. All right. I don't I don't know why you would
do this. It's so goofy to go and do this. Very strange. Very
strange stuff. I'll be real. Right here is where we were. Okay.
Vanel also admitted to using artificial intelligence to format
data into the Excel spreadsheet file. Oh, is a different time
stamp from a different day. Okay. Jesus.
>> If I ask an AI to do something for me, if I give it
a file and say, can you format this? It will never like spit
that file out onto the internet or do some random crazy [__]
with it. Right. >> Um, for safety's sake, you probably
shouldn't do that. I think you should probably have some professional
do that. That sounds like a safety risk. >> How's his so
cheap? How's his mother so cheap that he does this? Literally,
he could just pay. He's got software developers who work for
him or I don't know, not willing to let a professional handle
this and insisting on doing it himself. I know that a a court
of law will never be able to use that as evidence of something,
but I think the the court of like common sense. All right. Like
really, are we serious? It's not it's not even that he like doesn't
have the money. He it would be so cheap to pay somebody to do
this, but like he has to do it himself, right? That that seems
to me to be like, "Oh, that I think there's a reason you don't
want anybody looking at this."
Personally, I maybe not, but I that's where I go when I'm like,
"Oh, you've got millions of dollars and you refuse to just pay
some digital forensics expert. Seems like Pixie could find somebody
pretty >> Um, for safety, >> you Well, I can't hand
over anyone else cuz there's trouble. I'm just kidding. Um, that's
funny, right? That's funny and not a thing that actually Yeah.
>> You really Okay. >> Don't Don't feed chat GBT
child. >> Donald Trump just tipped $5. Wow. This Destiny
guy is crazy. If only it was my he was sucking on that recording.
I would have protected this, too. >> Okay. Thank you for
the five, Donald Trump. Jesus Christ. Oh, guys. Yeah, I I forgot
I'm supposed to shill sometimes. Guys, if you like the content,
you want to keep the stream going for longer, go ahead. Give
some subs on kick. Sub on kick. Sub on Twitch. Give some subs
on Twitch. You can use the exclamation point donate links, okay,
to get your TTS message right on stream. Exclamation point donate
in the chat. We'll get you both links. There's Kickbot. That
was that one. Okay. AI voices on Kickbot and Streamlabs. Streamlabs
saves your payment info in a better way. All right. So, you can
use any of those links. All dollars donated go to more time on
the stream. I appreciate all of you guys. Oh, also you can give
kicks. Go guys. All you got to do is go to the kick chat. All
right. Hold on. Let me open up my own my own stream here. You
go to the kickstream, okay? And then you click on this little
thing down here. This is a shop. You can like click on this this
little shop down here and you can buy kicks. And kicks are like
the best way to support the stream. Okay. You can give kicks.
Give kicks. All right. We are like six subs. Like six subs from
another hour on the stream. All right. Love you guys. Thank you
very much for all the support. Really appreciate it. Let's continue.
Boop. All right. So, we just watched these two. So, he uses chat
GPT to format.
He also
trying to I think he was trying to get it to um he was trying
to get it so that he could make something that would combine
the files together as far as I know. All right. Additionally,
Banell contends that because the original file name of the video,
as revealed by Solo Tiny Leaks, CECF1325
is not the same as either the file names that he sent to ABMC
1326. That proves that he never sent the video to ABMC. motions
pages 13 and 14. But Belle is comparing apples to oranges because
the two file names in ECF32-6
that he purportedly sent to ABMC on November 3rd, 2023 are not
file names. Instead, they are Google Drive links which merely
point to unknown file names. See declaration uh of Jesus Pena
paragraph 22. Thus, the evidence does not support Banel's contention
that he did not send the video to ABMC. Accord Well, also there's
what is it? The other thing he includes here, I believe, is Peach
saying, "I received those same URLs even though they're screwed
up." Um, and those those are not what was in those videos, right?
So, there is another piece here that they're not taking into
account. Um,
I would probably, if they were going to use that, I would probably
also submit the logs of Peach saying that she explicitly said
Destiny had leaked things to her. Right? If they're going to
use her as like a fact witness, then probably you need to include
her logs of her saying that Destiny had without consent leaked
like recordings to her. Anyway, uh thus this evidence does not
support Banel's contention that he did not send the video to
ABMC. Accordingly, defendant's motion should be denied because
it rests on inconsistent and tainted evidence and raises material
factual issues that only a jury can resolve. Eight. So, defendant
also claims that ABMC only saw the video because she allegedly
snooped through his computer on September 5th, 2023, pages 14:15.
This is purely a purely speculative claim or this purely speculative
claim is blied by NBMC's declaration and the evidence of her
conversation with her friend attesting to the fact that she received
the video via Google Drive link on or about November 3rd, 2023.
2 months later, defendant's speculative claim is nothing other
than an attempt to malign the witness. IBMC's declaration and
exhibit should not be disregarded. Defendant again attempts to
challenge ABMC's declaration ECF 492 and the screenshot exhibit
ECF861
because these arguments once again fail precisely because of
the defendant's spoilation. Banell claims that ABMC's declaration
and the exhibit should be disregarded because she failed to provide
evidence of the disclosure i.e. a screenshot of a message in
which Banell supposedly sent the video to ABMC. Page 15. However,
Banell knows that ABMC cannot do that because Banell deleted
all of his direct messages to her sometime in early 2025. ABMC's
declaration dated April 25th, 2025 clearly states, "I recently
reviewed my Discord account and realized that Destiny deleted
all of his direct messages to me on the Discord platform, including
the sharing of the video Pixie. I've retained copies of my messages
to Destiny, as well as my messages to other people about his
non-consensual sharing of explicit videos, ECF 492."
Multiple other women who received explicit content from Banell
have also attested to his deletion of his side of their message
thread after the November 29th, 2024 post by Solo Tiny Leaks.
See Declaration Hannah Brooks, Declaration Witness A B. And as
noted above, he has publicly acknowledged that there is no original
file because he deleted it. Vanel also asserts that the screenshot
the screenshot exhibit does not establish that he disclosed the
video to ABMC after the effective date of Cardi motion. um motion
paragraph 15 or page 15. This of course is nonsensical because
Benell did not even meet ABMC online until March 2023. Well after
the effective date of Cardi. Wait, did he actually say this in
a motion? Does not establish that he disclosed the video to ABMC.
Oh, I see. Sorry. Uh after the effective date of Cardi. I think
that's just a weird language thing. I don't think that means
anything. Um no, no, no. It sounded like duplicitus or something,
but it's not. It's just him saying that like also there's no
declaration there. It makes it seem like he's saying he might
have done it before, but that's not also not possible. This of
course is nonsensical because way after the effect of D cardi.
Thus, Benella's failed to present any valid reason to discard
the IBMC declaration or exhibit. The defendant's failure to serve
ABMC is not relevant. Defendant next argues that the the ABMC
evidence should be disregarded because he has been unable to
serve her with a subpoena. This contention fails for several
reasons. So, here's the thing, okay? The the reason it should
fail most first and foremost, most of all, is he never actually
subpoenaed her to depose her or ask her questions. He subpoenaed
her for like Discord logs. Now, I don't believe any of those
Discord logs would truly pertain to the evidence here, right?
I I don't think they were actually asking for the Discord logs,
unless I misunderstand. I don't think they're asking for the
Discord logs that would like prove or disprove like her conversations
with the friend or anything. So they're asking for like it was
like to support his conspiracy theory trying to tie like Briana
Woo into this and other people, right? So it wasn't even a subpoena
to depose her or ask any questions relevant to her her testimony.
This is a fact. Okay. Defendant next argues that ABM the ABMC
evidence should be disregarded because he has been unable to
serve her with subpoena. This contention fails for several reasons.
First, defendant offers no evidence of any effort to locate or
serve ABMC. Second, he provides no basis to claim that plaintiff's
council represents ABMC for their for purposes of service. To
the contrary, understein council expressly advised Mr. Breler
that they did not represent ABMC for purposes of subpoena, that
they were not authorized to accept service on her behalf, and
that they never instructed her to evade service. Third, council
recently obtained ABMC's last known address and promptly provided
it to Mr. Breler upon receipt. Defendant's position is further
undermined by his own conduct. His initial disclosures identified
11 individuals likely to have discoverable information, including
Rose. Yet, he has not produced contact information for any of
them. Plaintiff was forced to hire a private investigator to
locate Rose. Oh,
and the really funny thing here is he had additional information
when the when the case first started. He had additional information
that he put in his chat and tried to get Kiwi Farms to use. So,
he could have helped them find her and he did not do so. Crazy.
Finally, the authority defendant sites is in opposite. In opposite
effect out of place, inappropriate okay as it concerns expert
witness disclosures rather than lay witness contact information.
See Brown v NCL limited
defendants failure to serve ABMC is therefore irrelevant to his
motion and to the admissibility of the ABMC evidence. Okay, so
this is going to say that as it concerns expert witness disclosures
would be to dismiss this. So if you could somehow show an expert
witness is unreliable, then you could get rid of that. But it's
not meant to to
lay witness uh disclosures rather than lay witness contact information.
Wait. Oh, that like if you Oh, hold on. Sorry. Sorry. I misunderstood
for a second. This is saying that you can only like dismiss somebody's
testimony if you can't serve a w an expert witness rather than
a lay witness.
I feel like you should have to be able to talk to this person
in any case, but I don't believe they've tried to serve like
a motion for
uh so they haven't tried to serve her with a subpoena to depose
her as far as I know. Or they hadn't they didn't provide that
as evidence in their in their actual filing. Okay.
Conclusion. Defendant cannot use rule 12b1 to litigate the merits
of plaintiff's cardi claim because jurisdiction and the merits
are inseparable and because plaintiff's claim is neither immaterial
nor frivolous. dismissal was foreclosed. At this stage, where
discovery is ongoing in the material factual disputes abound,
the motion must be denied either outright or under rule 56 standards.
Plaintiff respectfully requests that the court deny defendants's
motion to dismiss in its entirety. Wherefore, plaintiff respectfully
requests that this court deny defendants's motion to dismiss
the amended complaint for lack of subject matter jurisdiction
and allow other uh and allow such other relief as warranted.
Respectfully submitted October 3rd, 2025.
Okay. All right. I I think that's like almost entirely it. Am
I crazy? I think that's like basically all of it. That's like
everything. Yeah, I think we've covered literally everything
here. Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Um, the one thing I didn't
put on screen, but I will now real quick is
just a little bit a little bit funny. And it is totally redacted,
so it's safe. Okay. But they gave like a redacted a unredacted
version of this to the court that would say basically like this
is Rose. We've actually subpoenaed her now and this is her date
of birth proving she was a minor. Read the logs. Oh, I forgot
about the logs. True. Forgot about that. Okay. I think this is
top to bottom. Yeah, it is. So, at some point today he goes into
DGG and says, "Dude, I'm going to lose it. It cannot be this.
Mimi for courtship plaintiff has produced 3,000 documents. this
piece of sent me. Every single Discord message in a super text
file and like 80% of what she provided were just messages from
our group chat. I am so annoyed. Like this whole thing is just
a giant joke to her. It's all memes and
ask ASOS. They paid some stupid expert forensics guy. Oh, I don't
know what he said. Must be asking about it. They paid some stupid
expert forensics guy to say my logs are tampered with and they're
comparing them to Solo's logs. We can't depose who isn't part
of the case. who we can't depose, who isn't part of the case.
Wait, you can totally depose them. What? Why would you literally
How could you not depose somebody who's like so material to the
case? What? That has to be like a first party witness to the
crime? Is Is there really no way you can subpoena that person?
Is that not allowed?
That that can't can't find him. Oh, maybe. You know, you know
who might have been able to find him? Just throwing it out there.
There is somebody who might have been able to find him, right?
That would probably be Rose. Rose might know how to find that
guy. And by the way, they've started throwing around this theory
that Solo was from the UK. Solo's primary reason for not wanting
to let Rose be docs in the initial leaks was that he it would
up his real life. I'm pretty sure there's every reason to believe
that he's somewhere in like Illinois. Like essentially every
reason to believe this. This is what he was responding responding
to was uh this Asos Destiny. Her lawyer is an immigration lawyer
and the whole shtick is make the pro uh is make the progress
as annoying as tire out the other side. Wow.
Wow. That's a totally
totally you know non ESL speaker right there 100%. Oh yes, Destiny.
Her lawyer is an immigration lawyer. We all we can all see it.
It's fine. We can all see it. It's fine. Okay. How can I even
speak for any of his? It's actually so
Destiny. That 50k is going a long way compared to whatever you
spent.
Dude, that's brutal. Why did that guy say that? That's That's
up. That's so up, dude. Man, how much? Didn't she say you're
spending like 700k or some [__] Uh, she's only spending
50. You're kind of getting screwed, man. You're kind of getting
[__] over.
Come elemental. She's not using that 50k. Her parents are loaded
and are covering this 100%. I don't I've never seen any reason
to believe that Pixiey's parents are loaded. Are you telling
me Pixiey's parents were loaded and she was like about to go
on a payment plan to put a Blue Yeti or some on layaway with
Straight Raid? Like she owed Straight Raid like 40 bucks and
she was like, "Can I pay you like $2 a month with like 3% interest
and like $5 down and her parents are rich?" Really?
Really?
Possibly.
But I don't know. Possibly. But I Man, whatever. So isn't just
claiming they're doing a proono now? I guess not. She's frugal,
bro. It's so annoying that I've spent so many days weeks of my
time compiling stuff and she hasn't turned over anything. It's
just frolicking around like nothing is even happening. And they
just frolicking around, brother. I don't know. Maybe Pixie is
doing better now. I just remember like shortly after this happened,
I don't think she's doing super well. She's just frolicking around.
Oh my goodness. Like nothing is even happening and they are just
playing games the whole time. By the way, this guy streams like
60 hours a week still. He's no aspect of his life has changed
significantly. His job is totally fine. Hasn't lost that many
viewers. That's crazy.
Uh, Super Boy asked Destiny, "What is Jane Doe's incentive for
dragging this case out with memes for this long? Is it just to
burn your reputation?" Super Boy, to attack my reputation and
waste my money since she has no reputation and never will. Hers
doesn't matter. And since her parents are apparently loaded,
it's not her money, so she doesn't care. I don't Okay, by the
way, he's literally frolicking the West Coast right now. Oh,
cool. Destiny, do you know why
UEI wants to bring you down so bad?
It feels so out of the blue. You were friends before.
DJ, who's like been in a coma for 10 months, 12 months? Destiny,
I I thought you guys were friends. What the [__]
happened, man? Hey, what what happened, dude? Weren't you guys
friends before? I thought you guys were close. Tyler Fortnite
because she's a spoiled white girl who's never faced any real
challenges/ opposition in her life and wants everything served
to her on a silver platter. I don't know. Like I actually Yeah,
I don't know what the [__] is going on here. Remember
when Destiny was like the anti- Red Pill guy or some
What is this?
What is this? Uh Destiny, how much longer do you think it goes
on for? Mind pride? No clue. It looks like they want to try to
make it survive the trial, but I have no idea why. She has absolutely
nothing.
Um,
listen, I firmly believe they want to make it survive to trial
because I think Destiny is an is an offensive enough person in
mind, body, and soul that a jury will convict him on intuition.
That is my theory. Okay. They'll just intuitively know this man
has done disgusting, horrible things. Not convict, sorry. Uh,
find him liable. They'll find him liable. All right. All right.
Anyway,
there's a there's like a little bit more to this conversation.
Give me a second. What was it? I think it's just the Jer. I think
it's just the jitter comment I need, right? Yeah. Hold on. I
can't tell if
I can't tell how this these replies are going, but okay. So,
here's where we left off. And Jader says something to zip zip.
Actually, it's possible Destiny leaked the video, Mr. Judge.
Oh, Jader is making a mistake here. Jader thinks that they're
like trying to argue that this has happened like conclusively.
They're doing a legal thing where they're saying, "You're trying
to dismiss this, but this fact hasn't even been established yet."
The fact of who leaked the video, whose account the video was
leaked from, has not been conclusively established. This is something
we should go over at trial with technical experts and all of
this stuff. Right, Jader, I haven't even gotten that far, was
going over the 25page expert witness thing. Can't believe they
have the had the audacity to say they provided 3,000 documents.
The what? The what? They they didn't have the what? >> Got
a phone. Hello. Oh. Oh, no. I'll tell them. Sorry.
Audacity calling. Just got a phone. Destiny POV. Okay.
Can't believe they they had the audacity
to say they provided 3,000 documents. I've got nothing from them
of substance. I am so triggered. Can't wait to get home and play
Final Fantasy Tactics. I assume FFT. Probably. Probably.
I would imagine. All right. I think that's all of the logs from
today. Oh, yeah. I I don't think Pixie's like necessarily poor
or her family's necessarily poor. I just don't think like the
categorization of them is loaded would make a lot of sense. Uh,
maybe they are. I just I don't think that's I don't know if that's
likely. Okay, there's bunch of
>> What if he did try to settle and Pixie said no? Would
we know about it? He seems to want to end the case in a hurry.
People do talk about as if the decision to settle is unilaterally
destinies. Lol. I'm not sure if Pixie would be even willing to
settle at this point. Her goal since the beginning was to punish
him in such a way that he would never do again what he did to
her and others too. I don't think he's reached that goal point
yet. He still doesn't show any remorse. No, I don't think he's
capable. I think it's a fool's errand to string remorse from
him. That's why we have other mechanisms to constrain shameless
offenders like sex offender lists. Bro, dude, Jader arguments
with Zip Zip. Okay, I think that's basically it. Uh, we could
do if we wanted to make it like a content day for this stuff,
we could go over some of the legal precedents for the URL stuff.
What was this one? There were some of these that I wanted to
take a look at later. Oh, that's not even close to what this
is.
Hold on. Hold on. I should do this. That'll get me. There we
go. Okay. Was that actually 3169?
Yeah. Okay. So, this is about what Cardi Oh, I now I didn't write
down what this was for. God, there we go. So, this was Cardi
defines to disclose or make accessible disclose with the consent.
Oh, this is a broad definition. Okay, hold on. what they would
mean by broad definition. Vara defines disclose as to transfer,
publish, distribute or make accessible 15 USC6851.
This is a broad definition and certainly broader than the defendant's
proposed definition. In construing a statute, the court must
begin and often should end as well with the language of the statute
itself. Uh publish means to disseminate or to the public. Distribute
means to give out or deliver especially to members of a group.
And to make something accessible means to make something capable
of being reached or seen. Ah man th this could be like a real
argument unfortunately uh none of the these terms require an
act that results in a change of ownership control or possession
as defendants argue by way of example a person can certainly
make a video accessible to others without seeding ownership control
or possession of that video to someone else. Defendants proposed
interpretation thus writes the word accessible completely out
of the statutory definition. According to defendants, they could
show the video to anyone anywhere so long as they use McCoy's
phone to play it. Perhaps by streaming it to a television or
larger screen, and so long as they did not provide copies, control,
or physical possession. Such a narrow interpretation of the term
disclosed is completely inconsistent with the idea of publishing
and completely ignores the concept of making something accessible.
The court concludes plaintiff's allegation defended allegation
defendants showed other patrons at a public restaurant. The video
falls within the statutory definition of disclosing. Oh, nice.
Oh, so showing this to somebody at a public restaurant was disclosing.
Now
that is not necessarily about make accessible here. Although
make access it's like saying that you shouldn't read as something
additional in the unfortunate thing here is okay I think they
had to be way more way more specific than just say make accessible
right because a textual reading which apparently the the federal
courts in Florida do a textual reading make accessible is so
broad that it's like if you've ever made it accessible in any
way it seems to possibly apply right it seems to so or at least
I should say it's probably something where
I think you can make the argument ments. Now, this one right
here, let's take a look at this. I was just going to look at
these cases to see. Although Cardi is relatively new, a new statute,
there's little case law interpreting it, at least one court has
upheld a continuous disclosure argument. So, let's see the circumstances
under which this was uh the continuous disclosure thing was upheld.
Okay. Okay, dude. Uh was that actually what I was looking at?
252. This is it. On February 7th, the court granted plaintiff's
exparte motion for TTRO, converted plaintiff's motion into a
motion for preliminary injunction and set a briefing and hearing
schedule on the preliminary injunction request. On February 28th,
2024, Defendant Ar John Ardo responded that he does not oppose
entry of preliminary injunction. Wait, that's not right. This
has to be some document in this case that I'm I need something
else here. Pacer monitor real quick. Nope. Sorry. I'm I'm just
looking for where this would be referenced. I need to actually
find a PDF with this though, don't I? Give me a second. No, not
that. God damn it. This This appears to be what they're saying.
That a
continuously make accessible argument was used here, but I don't
I don't see it. Hold on. Okay, dude. Come on, man. That's not
it. CV
Phoenix Enix, bro. I Oh, thank you. Thank you, Cya. Hold on.
So, this be in the Oh, god. Motion to continue.
Oh, man. Where in here would it be? Motion to seal documents.
Motion for protective order. So, not many of these things are
actually It seems like not many of these things are are actually
available when they when they reference this. Hold on. When they
reference this, looking at
at star six at star six, North Dakota. Oh, no. No, that's the
wrong one. We're looking at this one. District Arizona, February
7th. The do court found that although the initial disclosure
of certain videos was done before the effective data party, there
is a collable argument that defendant continued to disclose the
recordings. So even if Benell's initial transfer Okay. All right.
Oh, so you think you guys think we'd have a court listener thing
from December 7th? Possibly. Where did I just put this? Oh, here
we go. Sorry. February 7th is this guy. Okay, here we go. Make
accessible court finds plaintiffs are likely to succeed on the
merits of their claims under 15
colorable
plaintiffs alleged that John R initially published the 10 recordings
on the internet on July 3rd 23rd 2022 and August 10th 2022 which
is prior to 15 USC 6851's effective date of October 1st 2022.
Plaintiff als plaintiffs also assert though that the recording
continued to be made accessible on the internet until April 27th,
2023. Given the the statute under which plaintiffs seek relief
was only recently enacted, there is little case law on whether
the statute can be applied retroactively to disclosures made
prior to uh to October 1st, 2022. That said, plaintiffs have
a colorable argument that John R continued to disclose the recordings
after the statute's effective date because he allegedly continued
to make these videos accessible on the internet until April 23rd.
Moreover, even if plaintiffs can only show a serious question
going to the merits of their claims instead of a likelihood of
success, the court would nonetheless grant the TRO given that.
So, there's a they're saying there's a colorable argument in
the TTRO ruling.
Now, hold on. Where's the little three here? Where does uh where
does that? There's a little two. I can't see my little three
here. Hello. Two. Three. Oh, the verified complaint supports
that John R used the internet to disclose intimate visual depictions
of plaintiffs without their consent. Okay. So, so then we look
at the complaint and we will see
how he disclosed it, right? So, I'm guessing the disclosure is
done via like a public website that is indexable that is all
of these things. Hold on. Let's see here. So, both couples joined
an online website where they can meet other couples to engage
in online activities or activities. Jesus do publicly disclosed
the audio visual. So, he published them on motherless.
That's that's pretty different than the discord. Okay. That's
like That is very different. Wait, Mother is owned by Kick Online
Entertainment. No way. That's got to be a That's got to be a
different online entertainment. So, he published them on Mother
List. That's very different. And they're up there until
right? So, made accessible via like a public website. Oh, and
the titles of each of the published JD recordings in Ardo recordings
was the cops, city of residence, a police officer plus wife.
Yikes. Yikes, bro. Yikes, dog. I'd say this is probably although
this is precedent for saying the make accessible thing I I do
think it's like pretty hard to win that argument for making accessible
it is. So this one is it's publicly available. What is this?
This is a president Pixie team cited to say that make accessible
could just mean could be like granted if if it was originally
published if the video was originally published somewhere before
October 10th or sorry October 2022
then if it was still accessible on that same thing you could
like actually still have your Cardi claim be valid right but
the difference is the way it was publicized in this case is it
was on a public website that people go to and they could search
for it based on having all this stuff here, right? So Pixie's
argument here is like the Pixie team's argument is because
there was a possibility that if that if that URL made it somewhere
accidentally, it could have been indexed and it could have been
searchable via Google or some other search engine, you should
treat this as continue to publish. I don't think that'll hold
water. Not 100% sure. No, no, no, Slime. This is not This is
a different case. This is a precedent. And like there was metadata
here that was used that could be used to narrow down where these
people are from.
Right. So, a police officer who lives in a small community. It's
kind of rough, dude. That's what they are trying to argue, Cal
Game. This is a precedent they're citing that says, "Okay, well,
you if it was made available in some way, this counts. So, this
did count. This was allowed to proceed as in it was made available."
I think there there this is a way stronger case for make available,
right? Because it's on a portite that you publish it to a site
with like with like a title that could lead to those people specifically.
uh this is a way stronger case. So they're citing this precedent.
So it's possible
that make accessible transcends the um like something's originally
published before October 2022 and leaving it up after that does
mean that is still a violation. But I'd say this is a way stronger
example like that I would say it obviously applies to. I don't
know if Pixie's example obviously applies in the same way. That's
true ally. That is true. And it not still being accessible Solo
would not have had access. That's true. But it's sort of about
Yeah, it's a We'll see. There's There's There's arguments on
different sides. I don't know how it'll go. Um I I believe it'll
go against Pixie side, but I don't think that's like really what
she's resting her whole case on anyway, so it's almost certainly
fine. Funny DGC thing about this on LSF. What this? Oh, you guys
made a That's going to get hyper downloaded. That's not how filings
work. A filing is at its very strongest a claim. Definitely not
confirmation. I mean, they literally posted the uh Oh, yeah.
She's very upset. They literally posted the like certification,
the official certification from the people. This is just like
totally cope. I mean, it's I I was just saying. So, the thing
that changes here, we can go to the tweet real quick. The thing
that changes with this tweet, okay,
is one thing very specifically. The thing that changes here is
now it's not Kiwi Farms that is the source for this, okay? Now
people can go, "Well, based on evidence, based on Pixie subpoenaing
this person who's involved in the case, and based on her technical
expert finding and receiving an official certification from the
DMV of who she is and what her birth date is, we now know that
she was a minor, right? And you don't have to do the whole Kiwi
Farms thing. You can just say, "Oh, well, this has been proven
by uh by this Yeah, it's a matter of public record." Yeah. Yeah,
it is a matter of public record. I didn't I don't think I said
it was proven. I I think I I tried to keep it to a matter of
public record. That's what the tweet says, you know. Uh Free
Specific says, "I think holding Destiny liable for Solo getting
access through Rose isn't a super compelling argument." It would
be absolutely if if the disclosure had happened after like then
disclosing to Rose. Sorry, the disclosure to Rose would have
been a violation. I think I think Destiny should be held liable
for that because you are literally sending away somebody's intimate
material without their consent. I think it is still a violation.
It's just about whether or not the court would hold that uphold
that because of how how it affects things like downstream, how
other cases would be affected. Like there would be a lot of people
liable for this in a way that might actually be a concern in
terms of jamming up the court system. Probably implies a level
of being confirmed since it doesn't say the al I mean it is confirmed.
No, it's 100% confirmed. Jube. Yeah. No, it's 100% confirmed
though. It's not even confirmed by this. It's confirmed by all
of the stuff that came before this. Destiny, you know, giving
Kiwi Farms the photos of her that had never existed on the internet
before. Destiny telling Kiwi Farms where she went to college.
Destiny telling Yeah. So, it's all 100% proven. It's just a matter
of public record now. Uh, is the whole implied consent argument
over now? I I haven't been keeping up. I'm not sure. Uh, I don't
think so. I don't think it's over. I think it's just not been
relevant to any of the recent motions. Um, sure, TBK, but and
this is the first law that's ever really taken that into account.
I do agree with you, right? But for the the disclosure he made,
the nudes have never been leaked. Yep.
Okay. Anything else? People mad about the clip. It's just all
DGG posting in it. That's very funny. It's so pathetic how JTO
was literally begging his chat for 5 minutes for someone to clip
and submit this post. Was I do Did I ask somebody to post a clip?
Wait, shut it down. Did I ask you to post a clip? Is this just
totally invented? I don't think I did that. But maybe I did.
I definitely didn't do it for 5 minutes. What the [__]
did you just say? I I apparently I was doing that.
Pixie files a motion in case confirming that Rose was a minor.
Oh, the title here is confirming. Yeah, what what did I actually
say? I might have I might have misspoken here to be honest with
you. Rose has been served to be deposed. Cool. After finally
ascertaining Rose's legal identity, plaintiff has obtained evidence
that Rose's date of birth is October 30th, 2004.
Thus, when Banell was exchanging content with Rose between March
2, March of 2022 and until October 20 30th, 2022, Rose was a
minor. See exhibit B. Here official certification.
>> It just became very obvious to me listening to this
that I need a pop filter. I need to put the pop filter back on
the microphone. Okay. Why does nobody say these things to me?
I like hear the pop I hear literally like my
into the mic cuz I have to speak so close. Why don't you guys
just say, "Hey, put the pop filter on." What are you doing? of
Department of Motor Vehicles driving record. Damn. Damn.
Damn. Oh, I forgot. Another reason to include that she's a minor
is to inform the court that any that includes her before this
date is inadmissible as evidence. Right. Any any evidence that
Destiny has to remove, I believe that that is spoliation and
it will count against him. Wow. Okay. All right. Cool. Cool.
Cool. Cool. Uh-huh.